Speaker 1: Listen to this headline. A Trumpist
with guns wearing a clown wig was arrested at
Dairy Queen for threatening to kill Democrats.
That headline. I don't know that it would have
necessarily been a believable headline ten years
ago or 15 years ago in the United States. But
it is now a very real headline. You have to see
the story. There's a very good CBS News article
about it. Police armed man wearing clown wig
said he wanted to kill all Democrats. This is
unbelievable. The story goes. Del Monte,
Pennsylvania. A Westmoreland County man is
facing several charges after police said he wanted
to, quote, kill all Democrats. This is Jan. Or
maybe it's pronounced John Stover, 61 years old,
took a loaded gun into a Del Monte Dairy Queen
and police said the quick action of an officer
saved lives. This was five days ago, Saturday,
September 10th, when Belmont police say the wolves
walked into a Dairy Queen on state Route 66 in a
yellow safety vest and rainbow clown wig. Callers
told police he had a gun. Within a minute, Officer
Gregory Stahl was there. Multiple people were
inside the Dairy Queen at the time. And police
say a group of people, including several with
intellectual disabilities, were heading inside.
Officer Snell found Stover and took him into
custody. Well, great. That's all good. But look
at some of these details. Police found a loaded
40 caliber handgun and ammo on him. Still, ovi
allegedly told police he was, quote, undercover.
And he was, quote, working to restore Trump
to President King of the United States. He said he
was armed to, quote, kill Democrats and liberals
and to protect himself from, quote, drug
traffickers. When they started to look at
stories Facebook page, they found a history of
outbursts and threats. In the last two years,
Toby had been asked to leave two different
congregations leading up to the arrest.
Both congregations sent him letters saying
you had outbursts and you were threatening.
You can sort of imagine this person's political
views. He had photos on social media showing
support for Trump and a post saying Civil War
in 2024. As of the writing of this article.
Toby was not yet in jail but was in custody
awaiting a preliminary arranged arraignment.
So there is really two different stories here.
And every time we read about a story like this,
you see this mishmash of reactions thrown at the
wall, like, okay, the fact that this guy was a
Trumpist, this is the defenders will say the fact
that this guy was a Trumpist is irrelevant and a
mere coincidence. This is a mentally ill person.
This is a mentally ill person, fundamentally. And
it really has nothing to do with Trumpism. There
are three different important reactions to that.
First of all, it is true that there are mentally
ill people who will eventually become fixated on
something. Trumpism is one outlet. But were
it not for Trumpism, at least some of these
folks I agree with you would become fixated on,
you know, is it a 911 conspiracy? Is it a child
pedophilia conspiracy at a pizza place in D.C.?
Right. We've seen it. So some of these folks that
Trump is the Trumpist fascination is incidental.
And it could be about something else. But.
It is also true that Trumpism is attracting
more of these folks than just kind of like
middle of the road Democratic Party
politics. Trumpism is attracting more
of these folks than social progressivism. So
we can't write that off. Yes, mental illness,
sure. But there's something about Trumpism
here that is attracting these folks. Secondly.
If you really believe that what's at issue here
is mental illness, why isn't more being done by
the very right wing that claims this is all about
merely mental illness? It's not about Trumpism,
and it's certainly not about guns. Why aren't
they doing more to prevent mentally ill folks
like this guy from being able to have guns because
the guy had guns and ammo, which as of right now
is believed were purchased legally. So the very
people who want to do nothing about the guns and
say this is about mental illness, they aren't
doing anything to get guns out of the hands of
mentally ill people. And we know that there were
two churches here who had sent him off and said,
you can't be here, you're threatening, etc..
There should be some mechanism and it should be a
requirement for the church if they had a knowledge
that this guy owned firearms to report to someone,
here's someone who's unstable. We've kicked them
out for these reasons. We believe they have guns.
It should be looked at. Also, last thing, the
number of stories related to like fast food
and convenience stores. Recently, Mike Pillow was
raided by the FBI at a Hardee's drive thru. This
guy is at a Dairy Queen. I hope that if Trump ever
does get arrested, he'll be found at KFC, elbow
deep in a bucket of chicken. That would really
be the final poetic chapter to this entire thing